hi so I'm Cameron I eat a lot of
bastardized american sushi and i work
for easybib.com as a front-end developer
and I'd like to talk to you a little bit
today about using domain driven design
in the browser domain driven design is a
practice that's been used in server-side
technologies and for desktop
applications since the 90s and in some
form or another like long before that
but the state of the web right now is
the applications are becoming more and
more complex on the browser and so I'm
advocating that it's time to start using
this for our client side of development
as well this is the world's creepiest
cat gift to say let's get started so one
of the main tenets of domain driven
design is that the job of software is to
solve problems that have to do with a
particular domain so we're going to
start really high level on this and then
we're going to go really really low
level down to the technology and will
actually build an application using that
local storage and angular to get the
html5 bit in there so the question is
that if that's the job of the software
what is a domain so a domain is an area
of expertise so it could be an industry
feel like accounting or it could be just
something that you're interested in like
penguins or just a part of life like
social networking so some examples of
domains that applications are built to
solve ok cupid is built to solve the
problem of matchmaking facebook is built
to solve the problem of social
networking and all the things in that
domain some all is there to solve the
domain of data analysis photoshop is
there to solve the domain of graphic
design and EasyBib is built to solve the
domain of academic research so the
basically what domain driven design says
is that a successful piece of software
starts by focus
the domain but that's a pretty vague
thing to say how do I focus on the
domain well one of the first things that
you need to do is you need to seek
understanding from people who understand
the domain better than you do if you're
building an application for bankers then
you probably better talk to a banker and
get some understanding of banking
because you know software probably or
something like that and you probably
don't know banking that well so do me
and experts are sometimes also called
business stakeholders or product owners
so how do you identify an expert in your
domain will some examples these people
shot Shana might think if I were to
build the next day OkCupid and that i
did a good matchmaking algorithm I'd
probably ask these like Orthodox Jewish
matchmakers how to do that if I wanted
to build a social networking application
I'd probably get some info from somebody
who's a really good social networker
like Neil taparia who yeah he is just
take my word for it if I was building a
data analysis app I probably ask a
statistician for some information about
how to do data analysis I've always
going to build the next photo shop I'd
probably talk to a graphic designer
about the domain of graphic design and
if I were going to build an application
to do research then I would probably ask
my friend Ali Cloyd who's a research
librarian and knows a lot about research
just take my word for it so after you've
talked to a domain expert about the
domain then you need to create a model
of that domain that you can then use to
craft your software so what's a model a
model is a blueprint of the domain that
exists in your brain so this image is to
represent that domain experts think in
terms of jargon there on the left and
apparently developers think in terms of
binary and when they have conversations
then they can merge those two things
into a model that you can use to build
software so here are some common
misconceptions about what a model is the
model is not source code you have code
that reflects the model and your code
contains words from the model but it's
just an implementation of
model the actual model exists in your
brain the model is not the database
sometimes this is that misconception
that comes up from the term MVC
sometimes model-view-controller becomes
data view controller but the model is a
lot more than data its business logic
and it's something that exists in your
mind and the model is not a diagram the
model is something that exists in your
mind the diagram is just a picture of it
so here's some of the perks of using a
model if you're anything like me you sit
in a lot of meetings with tech heads and
you have no idea what they're talking
about most of the time because they're
talking about implementation details but
a model gives us a shared vocabulary
that we can use to talk about technical
problems with non-technical people and
technical people all the same it also
helps us to scale ibly handle complexity
so I don't know if you've ever had the
experience of starting out brand new on
a project and thinking oh I'm going to
build it right this time and then three
months or six months down the line you
have this completely unmanageable mess
and you think how did I get here that's
probably because you had a complicated
domain and so if you understand how to
separate the domain concerns from your
application concerns it can really help
you to attack the head on here's another
good example of an application gone
wrong another great benefit of using a
model is it's manageable knowledge
sharing your front end person is
probably not going to ever understand
everything that your database person
knows and vice versa but we can all
understand the model on the domain
that's knowledge sharing so the question
is how do i transport basically how do i
transport this information out of my
domain experts brain and turn it into a
model that i can use to build software
so there are three tools that we're
going to use and John Paul and I are
going to demonstrate this in a little
bit but the main ones are just have to
talk and then you're going to diagram
some things using uml and then you
better work through some use cases as
well so before we do that i'll just talk
about some of the main building blocks
of domain driven design one of the
biggest ones is entities entities are
the nouns of your application the stuff
the the
Jack's so basically an entity is
something that is persistent and unique
so persistent you know you shut down the
application you leave the website you
come back later and the information is
still there it gets stored somewhere and
it's also unique you can't ever have two
of the same entity in the single
application so you need some kind of way
ensuring that it stays unique and that
is usually a key or a combination of
properties of some kind so some examples
of entities a user is usually identified
by their email so you never have two of
the same user in a system bank accounts
are identified by account numbers you
can imagine the problems that would come
out if you had two of the same bank
account a shipping route might be
identified by some arbitrary ID like a
number and then a book or a product
should be identified by an ISBN or skew
value objects are objects that aren't
unique but they are persistent and so an
entity its properties are usually value
objects a good example would be right
here the user is an entity and it has to
be unique but the name is not so it
could be shared between different users
a factory simply simply abstracts
construction logic away from the entity
so if you have to do something
complicated to construct something make
a separate object for it a good example
would be a printer the job of a printer
is not to put screws into the printer
and to load itself up with cartridges
and put all these components together
it's just to put ink on paper so service
is a verb of an application if you have
a job to do and you're not really sure
which object should be doing it then
it's probably a good job for a service a
service can touch lots of different
parts of an application an example on
our website would be a citation service
which you give it the name of a book and
it returns a formatted citation for you
so it might go to an API to get
information about that book and then
pass that information into a book
factory and then send that to a
repository to save analytic information
and finally format it into a view so
that service could kind of like put all
of those different pieces together and
finally a repository is a black box for
data so basically you take an entity and
you put it into the repository and you
save it
and you don't know where it goes but it
gets persisted somehow and you take it
back out of the you know you can take it
back out later you can change it and put
it back in and save it and it gets
persistent somehow the idea behind a
minute repository is that you have a
single interface for any given number of
data persistence methods so that you
don't have to worry about protocols and
all these different low level
implementation things so that's why it's
called a persistence abstraction layer
more commonly a database abstraction
layer so the last big piece here is
layered architecture in an application
it's really helpful if we have our
concerns separated so what I like to do
is divide it up into separate layers all
of my domain code goes into one
directory my business logic goes into
one directory if there's anything that's
application-specific that has to do with
an environment or can only run in a
console or has to do with migrating a
database it goes into my application
layer and then I have utilities layer
that can contains code that can be used
across different domains and that's more
or less an example of all those things
so here are some rules for layered
architecture information flows one way
up so your application layer can contain
references to objects in your domain
layer but not the other way around
application layer can contain object
references to objects and your utilities
but not the other way around and that
makes it so you don't get tight coupling
and it also makes sure that you don't
have any circular dependencies alright
cool so let's get some practice with
some help from our very own John Paul so
this is a this is a real life
conversation that I had with Ali coydt
that research librarian because I wanted
to know how to build an application that
uses the Cornell note-taking system I
don't know anything about the Cornell
note-taking system and so she was my
domain expert and this is how that
conversation went and we'll kind of like
build a model using this and I'll try to
demonstrate here without a whiteboard
what this process should look like as
well so
take it away so so Cameron I'd like you
to build an application for me that
makes it easy for students to use the
Cornell no dates what's the applications
supposed to do I guess you have to
explain the Cornell note-taking system
first will help students with a very
specific style of taking notes but I
know all about because I'm doing expert
big points either a lecture or a booklet
they're reading whatever subject the
student is pulling information from they
need to be able to enter very specific
big points from that they need to be
able to enter hints like very small 7
summaries very brief points or one hair
and hints there needs to be a way for
them to see their hands which should
next to their big points without seeing
the big points so that by looking at
their hints they're forced to come up
with what the hint sneak under the hints
and big points there should be a space
where they can write a summary of all of
the information they've just gathered or
whatever the boat or the goals for what
they want to get out of this lecture or
the book or whatever really then they
use the whole thing to review for a test
or quiz or a paper there's a specific
set up involving two columns a skinny
column on the Left where the hints hit a
larger column numbers right for their
big points they write their big points
first into large column they then right
there hints in the skinny column across
the bottom is a section where they write
their summary and at some point they
cover up the large column and or the
summary with only the hands remain
invisible and there has to be infinite
ssible ok so the layout of the page
looks like this is what I'm thinking yes
exactly that so that was a ton of
information let's start over it looks
like we have some objects that we're
dealing with in the Cornell note-taking
system so in the diagram that I'm about
to draw a box is just an object that
we're dealing with so we have a big
point we also have a column and we have
a summary
Oh dad did something weird their summary
so can there be more than one hint for a
big point actually for each big point
are meaningful I additionally be
relevant when you cover up the big
points you should be able to look at the
end and figure out what it means in a
broader context so if you're listening
to a lecture on dogs and one of the
points is that there are hundreds of
breeds of dogs in the world if you were
to write that down hundreds 100 s
because the idea is to condense it as
much as possible hundreds of degrees
that's your big point and your hint is
many you're setting up this system of
hints with memorization so when you
write the summary you can bring it all
together you're not just spitting out
facts you're able to synthesize all of
your hands and big points into one big
picture okay so we want to provide
people do we want to provide people with
the ability to make more than one hint
for a single big point or do we want to
make it so they can only get one hint
the hint could also be a questionnaire
sentence I would say it has to be one
item but it doesn't necessarily have to
be one word I said would suffice for an
item if you needed if you were thinking
that you would need multiple heads when
it really should be one sentence or one
question or it should be broken into
multiple point so a piece of text so I'm
wondering if a hint is really an entity
in its own right or if it really is just
text that belongs to the big point this
means that the hints belong to the big
point this relationship here each big
point also has text that's going to be
displayed so that's full text and the
summary is just a string or a piece of
text so do we want to give students the
ability to highlight a piece of text and
tie it to a big point oh it sorry each
big point also has text that's going to
be displayed like the full text of the
idea and that would be a bullet point
okay great so a a column contains big
points or it could also contain hints
depending on where it is
so that means it has more than one big
point a call on my DS either display the
hint or the full text and the summary is
just a string or just text so do we want
to give students the ability to
highlight a piece of text and tie it to
a big point the summer should be only
their their original thoughts and words
that's the point of a summary to see if
you were listening and can get can you
put it into your own words so summer we
shouldn't have any copied text in it it
should all be original ok so the summary
is going to be free text this is going
to be a lot simpler than I thought does
this look about right a summary contains
texts oh oh here we go text string a
summary contains text a column contains
big points and it might either display a
hint or the big point depending on where
it's positioned when you do it by hand
on a piece of paper you have two columns
hints and big points of their own
separate thing the idea is that you
cover up one column and you see the
other does that make sense yeah so hints
and big points have their own separate
columns I'm also thinking that there are
two other big objects here we have
project
oh yeah yeah well maybe I could put that
up on the meet up afterwards yeah so we
have a project would you call that a
project the full thing that you're
working on it's probably more accurately
lesson or subject it might be subject
okay so this this whole thing could be
one subject what if they went to
multiple classes on the same subject
will be like if I do Cornell notes for
math English and science I would have
three sets of notes for each one okay so
i think subject is probably the best
description for this i'll change the
subject a subject contains one summary
and lots of big points and it contains
two columns those collins have a loose
relationship with big points so columns
don't actually own the point the note
the the subjects does but we have two
columns they display either the hint or
the full text and then we have one other
thing which is our user which has one
subject which has more than one subject
and so this is going to need to have a
name and i'm not actually going to draw
all this out right now because we're
running a little bit behind on time but
the idea is we have a subject and we
also have a user that has multiple
subjects so do we do we need to know
anything else like the school that the
user is coming from like what the school
is or anything yeah so it's it's
individual use right ah yeah sorry I'm
paraphrasing now perfect so I'm glad to
send it up being such a simple model
thank you very much to JA ok cool so now
let's just get that I actually built out
this application and so let's just get
down to brass tacks and just blow
through really quick what they
architecture of it is so the first thing
that I did when I built this application
is it turns out that in this after I
refined it there are really only two
entities that we're dealing with so I
wrote those entities the first is big
point and the other one is subject and
each of these are implementing something
that is it's called entity context which
is a library that actually gives you a
base class for repositories so if you
implement this scheme object on your
entities then it'll actually
build those for you it'll pull them out
of local storage and it will give you
actually actual JavaScript objects have
all these properties and I'm pulling in
all the tools that i'll be using right
here so i'm using graph j/s which
basically builds an object graph from a
plain old JavaScript object and then
entity context plus requirejs and
angular which just makes it a lot easier
to do this stuff so after I've defined
my entities then here we go after I
defined my entities then I'm going to
add a couple of other things a factory
for giving me blank blank entities
basically a blank big point and a blank
subject and I'm also going to add a
repository so I'm just going to take
this base class called repo and I'm
going to read it or extend it so that it
has these different parameters so that
it can pull these things out of local
storage and then I'm going to add in
some application logic first I'm going
to put in view models we don't want to
argue why to have direct access to our
business objects so I'm going to make a
big point on a subject view model and
then for the pages that we're going to
be having there's going to be a lot of
extra data that they're going to need in
a lot of extra methods and so these are
going to be the view models for those
cool and then after that i'm just going
to add in the views for the two
different pages we're going to have
we're going to have one page that's a
list of subjects that you can select and
then another page that's a detail for
each subject that's going to show you
all the big points for that subject and
once that is finished I'm going to tie
it all together into one great big
main.js file where I'm going to specify
all my paths and then just do a little
bit of routing and add some controllers
I'm going to get the hang of this I'm
going to get to go in the right
direction here pretty soon yeah that was
it and then finally i'm just going to
bootstrap at all using one index HTML
file and add a little bit of styling
there are going to be a couple of
utilities that I'm going to need to pull
in one of these is an angular directive
and the other one is going to be a
remove directive so this goes into my
utilities folder you kind of see that we
have to set up so that it has the three
different layers that we talked about
earlier and step 9 I'm just going to add
in a server application that simply
spins up a server and then serves up
files either from the client directory
the client application or from the root
so we can talk about this more if you
want to after but basically this makes
it really easy for your application to
become isomorphic if you want it to but
we're not going to deal with that right
now because it's a really simple
application and then last step I'm just
gonna do npm install that were installed
to get all my dependencies that I'm
going to need and then I'm gonna just a
spin up my app server index J yes guy
and let's see what our application looks
like oh you caught me I had already
built it but this is actually what we
just built so we can add a new subject
if we want to such as programming and
then I can go into my programming
application and I can add a hint and a
full text for hint and this is sort in
local storage so it'll be stored right
there even if I real web page this is my
summary yeah and you might have noticed
we we didn't interface directly with
local storage this whole time which
makes it really easy to port this over
to a rest application or using web
sockets if we want to switch over our
persistence because it's going to
implement that same interface and that
is more or less how that works so if you
just want some information about the
stuff that's in this presentation graph
chance is at that URL in any context is
that URL they're both really young and
highly unstable but I'm looking
contributors and yeah we're also looking
to hire UI and UX engineers so if you're
interested in this kind of thing feel
free to come up and talk to me
afterwards but that's it thank you
oh this is what a picture of this
yeah absolutely this is just the kind of
thing that usually happens in a shop I
mean like most the time you'd rather
have your developers spending their time
talking to someone rather than doing
research but uh if any other resources
that help for you that's great I do I
yeah I'm it's something I'm kind of
trying to feel out because I don't feel
like a lot of people are really doing it
hardcore in the browser right now so
it's just taking a lot of experimenting
but yeah
or positrons and factories and
bigger this language and how you
interact with your customer der
madiha you know where you see that Tony
yeah I'd say it's it's both of those
things i find benefit from the biggest
thing for me is just scale I mean I've
worked on applications that have used
this kind of discipline in the server
before and when these applications
become much larger and more and more
complex it's way easier to scale them if
you have this level of separation of
concerns which is really what DDD DDD
comes down to is just separation of
concerns it's just an extra level of
discipline on top of that the main
modeling is the most important part and
that the coding patterns especially but
more generally in the modern era or
becomes backlash from the Java style
mountains of layered abstraction
differentiating between entities and
value objects is valuable and having
like storage layer a repository and the
DD sense it's different from across
Correa's like a abstraction of your
storage layer which is a very java ee
like what's my most welcoming database
then it's more like there's a conceptual
idea of things go here and then it's a
common pattern that shows up it domains
so it's very easy to like get drawings
so especially because layer architecture
is in the book because it's you know
only get drawn into the Java world in
JavaScript just because you're modeling
your domain at the same time
so to give you the background for
without mention the major designs that
book is a gigantic sort of I like the
part that Eric the author trying to most
important to eat regrets pudding as the
second half ago because people quit
early is the part about like the larger
scale issues like founded context you
know the your terminology and the way
figure out problem changes between
sections of your application you know
maybe maybe that's a business tank maybe
it's an implementation thing but this
this needs to be isolated from this
other part of the business that thinks
about the apparent noble.com right used
to work because we had the main hook
store bought books and organized I'm
going to completely different way like
folders and things like that in your in
your library whereas we work in
education side so we have like courses
and terms kind of like a book actually
meant a different thing because we
didn't include periodicals we only and
we did include textbooks so like
the idea that you just separate off
things and structure your domain and
larger scale was a lot of stuff that
comes in the latter parts of Gd I think
it's pretty valuable because it you can
really get confused if you're like well
should we just have one book entity for
all prints available and like no that's
a horrible idea yeah um yes so further
reading very good anything else yeah
glossed over the part where you said the
obscure one column yeah so I whipped
this out today like in the last three
hours so I just didn't get around to
hiding back column but you would just
use an angular directive to do that what
we're concerned about as part of your
design why is it not mentioned there's a
reason that you didn't mention it part
of your design that you're capturing
as part of the domain design you mean as
part of the model because it's a UI
detail if you can deal with it just by
adding an angular directive you just
click on this and it goes away I would
say it's not really part of your domain
it's part of your application to that
kind of ants make sense to certain
extent but seem to be business rules for
when it's obscured and when it's not who
it applies to in fact you don't mention
any actors at all in your design is just
an implementation detail as well well
there's a lot of things that I don't
talk about in here because it's yeah
it's pretty slapdash this particular
application but yeah I would just say
that's not it's not persistent and it's
also not something that's necessarily
going to apply to multiple applications
and so it would just stay out of that
domain layer if this were more like an
application layer kind of presentation I
definitely would dwell on that more
yeah that wouldn't make any sense you
have 0 or 1 but no more than one it
seems to me that the rule is really that
you can obscure the full text column but
there really wouldn't be a reason to
obscure the hint column that might be a
lack of my understanding of the domain
you should take this off yeah maybe
thank ya